how do you like it baby are you talking
about the word about food
no like the you know the view the
atmosphere
the vibe the energy it was very good
it's very peaceful i like
it's very peaceful remind me my hometown
you miss bulgaria yeah
yeah the most things i miss is my family
yeah
every time i hear about georgie's family
in bulgaria
it makes me feel like you're a little
sad because i don't know if georgie's
told his family about me or his friends
whenever i ask about his life his world
he's a little bit closed off it makes me
feel like georgie's hiding things for me
i do want to get to know your family you
are technically married
and we're dating because you're
separated legally and
filing for divorce and i mean
i don't really feel like your family
truly knows who i am
i feel like i've been in the background
a little bit i've heard my name
here and there i don't like intrude i'm
waiting for that true introduction
i mean with annika aspen you've been on
many face times you know you met my
sister you met my father my mom like
we've
invited you in our world
all right what's going on with you guys
are you guys good
you know we've had a little tip for tats
over things
that i'm like questioning because i'm
like okay maybe i don't know him as well
as i thought i did
but it's not only that it's social media
that can affect relationships it's
affected yours
in the back of my mind i can't stop
thinking about who's leaving this fire
emoji to you
i think i'm stressing out cause i'm
thinking and feeling the worst right now
and i've had past relationships like
this and i
don't want to feel it again
[Music]